It just seems like a strange thing to do.
A documentary on.
Documentaries are killing it lately.
[inaudible] Kelly,
he thought he was flying free isn't on pitches that then that documentary came
out.
He's fucked.
Yeah,
he's fun.
He's arrested.
Yeah,
they just released him.
Did you see when they released him,
like he,
he leaves jail and he has to walk through a throng of people people and there
was script and some,
the woman was yelling at him,
calling him.
They took his music off iTunes.
Really?
They took that all of shit and all the artists who worked with them took their
music down.
Like let's say Michael Jackson did get convicted of molesting kids.
Could you still listen to his music?
Could you imagine your separate,
do you know Tony Hinchcliffe?
I don't want to give away a bit.
He has a fucking hilarious bit about that.
He has a hilarious bit about really heard.
I bet he's redoing it now because I don't think it's on a special on his last
special.
I don't think it's on,
so,
no,
I heard it.
Yeah,
Dude.
Tony Hinchcliffe.
He's got some fucking,
he's got this new bit about transgender athletes.
What does it say?
Their daycare affiliated woman who bailed R Kelly out of jail receives bomb
threat.
It's a mystery.
Woman bailed him out and he's looking like shit right there.
It's been stressful time.
Fuck yeah,
we're going to do.